So this sample, it’s a very, very interesting
sample; it’s arsenic. So this is quality
arsenic.
So arsenic used to much more common in the
community than it is nowadays. It was used
as a pigment in the nineteenth century for
green wallpaper contained copper arsenite,
because there weren’t any other good green
pigments to make the wallpaper. And when the
rooms were damp, Victorians didn’t like
opening the windows in their rooms, then mould
would grow on the wall. And because arsenic
is poisonous to most life forms the mould
would convert the arsenic into a volatile
compound, trimethylarsine, and the trimethylarsine
went into the air and several people were
killed by the arsenic coming from their wall
paper.
Now arsenic as we know is very toxic and there
have been a number of very high profile and
very famous cases of people that have poisoned
perhaps their partners or their business partners
using arsenic. Okay, so I’m going to very
carefully take this vial out. He says very
carefully then knocks it really hard.
Arsenic was also used quite widely by people
to dispose of husbands, wives, lovers. Though
now it is much less common. It is used in
the electronics industry for getting electronic
properties for making transistors. And also
it is still sometimes used for medication
for feeding to livestock. It is only quite
recently that the use of arsenic has been
banned as an additive to chicken feed in the
United States.
So here you see the arsenic powder okay. Now
this is a metallic very dark metal, but I’m
not going to open this because like I said
it’s very, very toxic. It’s a very dark
metallic sample, you can see a very fine powder
in the bottom of this vial. Now I’m going
to put this back in before I get any on my
skin because it’s a very toxic material
and I don’t want to expose myself.